the way it's worked into my life
curiosity and making movies and
television shows it's enabled me to be a
better curator of what's an original
idea i think our first reflex is to go
to the internet as opposed to skiing out
new people to meet because that's really
disrupting your comfort zone I mean
every time I do this it's challenging
it's just that isn't going to be your
natural reflex your natural reflex is
going to go to Google a subject Google
the person Oh yet IMDb and that is how
it's going to work but what you want to
do is you want to try to figure out how
extraordinary people become
extraordinary do I think kids normally
just go to the Internet and and just
stop there probably because you are
getting out of your comfort zone meeting
a new person if you treat it as an act
of generosity that you are wanting to
share part of your life with somebody it
will reduce your anxiety when you reach
out to somebody you'd go beyond just
asking a question you might give them a
piece of information like when I've met
some famous designers like Vivienne
Westwood I come to Vivienne Westwood
immediately with an olive branch I
immediately say to vivian vest Westwood
what do you think of this new soundtrack
or what do you think of this piece of
music because look designing it goes
hand-in-hand with music I mean you know
music is going to be have some
compatibility to fashion ultimately what
I'm trying to do is find a way to
intersect with how their psyche it
actually works so what I'm trying to do
is understand very quickly what is it
that they are going through emotionally
because emotionally what they're going
through is going to relate to what they
do and achieve professionally and what's
deeper than that
is what do they think is their purpose
in life what is valuable to them I mean
what has meaning in their life I made it
probably the deep truth of of what we're
trying to understand within our solar
system as human beings and even as we
try to get outside of our solar system
what is this all about